m
[Musique]
surtout
ambiance caliente avec le groupe sabor
latino un habitué des lieux
traditionnellement le central comment ce
lundi soir la veille de l'ouverture du
festival
mais normalement il n'est pas le seul
bar accueillir des concerts
sauf cette année si c'est le festival
c'est comme tous les ans
[Musique]
maritime que je suis seul et je
comprends pas c'est le seul bar où il ya
quelque chose
1 1-10 début de printemps de gauche
trouve ça dommage parce que c'est quand
même l'événement sur bourges de l'année
où il va y avoir beaucoup de monde je
suis un peu déçu pas le choix donc mais
un bon plan pour ceux qui aiment les
rythmes latinos endiablés et rullier
personnel du train tant qu'étudiante
danseurs de salsa se sont donnés
rendez-vous du site
pour bien commencer le festival pour moi
c'est dès le premier soir mais prenez
soir c'est important on commençait
direct et se mettre dans l'ambiance est
donc le central bar c'est parfait pour
ça et salsa ce soir ben oui salsa c'est
un groupe qui vient ici depuis plusieurs
années et toujours au maximum ce groupe
donc je les suis partout je suis partout
c'est un groupe génial le sabord latino
250 concerts sont prévus en plus du
programme officiel dans les bars et
restaurants de la ville
des spectacles gratuits qui attire
toujours le public avait prévu de voir
d'autres artistes
moi personnellement non mais je veux
aller plutôt dans les bars sur ça sympa
et confrères des nouvelles personnes et
puis
aussi de musique
très bien
[Musique]
alors en famille ou entre amis
l'opération printemps dans la ville se
poursuivent jusqu'à dimanche
ah bon